[Applause]
[Laughter]
thank you so much for being here
i know this has got to be such an
intense time for you people have been
lining up for days uh
and and theaters are sold out everywhere
and there's this
mania that surrounds the release of this
film can you go out in public
and just walk around or is it too
intense um it kind of varies i've
i've been in i've been in london for a
while and uh i find it's
very different in la new york london
it's they're they're good examples of
how people respond in new york they're
like
don't flatter yourself honey i was not
looking at you and you're like great
great just
you know that's that's perfect for a
nice thing to say to you
when you're just walking down the street
hey don't flatter yourself
yeah yeah yeah it's a distinct look it's
like a
yeah and then in london people are sort
of overtly polite
and um yes sort of uh just want to be
nice and
polite and they don't get too crazy but
here it must
get very intense do you ever i mean some
celebrities when they
get to this sort of stage that you're at
they wear a disguise have you ever done
anything like that have you ever
put on you know made yourself look
different so you could just walk around
right um well this isn't real
no let me see that wig comes right off
yeah
you're not kristen stewart at all it's a
good disguise
um no no i don't know i i i tend to
i get by very easily it's weird i think
um
i don't know i think rob kind of gets
he's very approachable
yeah i mean not to say that i'm i just
think that it's easier for people to
talk to guys i don't know it's sort of
like
he's some guys are harder to i've
noticed just
anecdotally i've just noticed in my that
women can look very different they can
just put a hat on and keep their head
down whereas guys we
i mean people i can be encased in
lead wearing a full disguise and people
like conan o'brien's in there
you know i just look like big bird from
sesame street walking down
well you guys are bigger maybe yeah and
and uh
obviously twilight has fans of all ages
but such a strong reaction from from
young people
is it weird when you sometimes meet uh
or you talk to an older person who
doesn't know doesn't understand how big
it all is do you know what i mean yeah
like well that sounds fun good luck with
that
yeah um it's funny to say to your own
grandmother you're like
no i know i've done movies and stuff but
this is it's a big deal grandma you know
what i mean it's like
and so they're just like well we'll see
hang in there
with your vampires and werewolves
well we had uh this is a true story i
had a party and andy you were there this
is years and years ago but
jim carrey you know and no celebrities
ever came to my party but he just
happened to be in the neighborhood and
he came to my house and my mom was there
and she was over in the corner talking
to him
this was not long after like ace ventura
and
just all these massive smash hits and my
mom's talking to him and afterwards i
said mom what were you talking to him
about and she said well
he's an actor
[Laughter]
and i told him you stick with it
my boy had trouble but he's stuck with
it and i just said
she i said mom go to work cause she she
worked i said go to work tomorrow and
tell everyone that you told jim carrey
to stick with it
yeah well you tell me who it is tell me
who it is i said just go to work and so
she called me the next day and i just
heard people
laughing at my mom i showed her but yeah